depuis avril 2019 la caméra corporels
fait partie intégrante de l'équipement
que portent tous les jours les 1126
agents qui patrouillent calgary était
projeté center on ne cliquent choc et
direction policière doit être
enregistrée la police estime que non
seulement les caméras sont devenus
essentiels pour mener des enquêtes mais
que ce point de vue améliore la
transparence et apaise les tensions
rendent un avis favorable que sont loin
de partager les militants du mouvement
black live faveur de calgary non
seulement les caméras ne capte pas
toujours le contexte précédent une
intervention policière
mais avoir accès aux images peut prendre
du temps selon la présidente du
regroupement local de blackglama veulent
les caméras corporels ne règle en rien
ce qu'il décrit comme le manque de
supervision indépendante des forces
policières
la reprise au canada l'utilisation des
caméras est encore très récente et
surtout loin d'être répandu
si l'expérience de calgary est souvent
cité en exemple on en sait concrètement
peu de choses soutient cet expert
calgary depuis encore plus longtemps
[Musique]
aux etats unis le port de caméras
corporelle par les policiers minneapolis
qui ont arrêté josh sole n'ont pas
empêché samares selon le professeur rémi
boivin leur effet sur la réduction du
profilage racial ou usage de la force
reste encore à prouver simple et
efficace aux toujours donc c'est pas
bien si c'est pas parce que on équipe
les bonnes si nécessaire les effets
qu'on veut qu'il le service de police de
calgary dit avoir conclu récemment une
étude sur l'efficacité de caméras en
attendant le dépôt du rapport
plusieurs services de police au pays ont
pris contact avec leurs homologues de
calgary il s'intéresse au programme
devrait-il sont inspirés là aussi les
avis divergent ici mathieu gaye et radio
canada qu'ailleurs